so we wanted to give you a preview of
the stars they're going to be performing
that night and our host michael yo and
nikki novak take you down the list who's
ready for an exciting countdown to 2022
i'm actor host comedian michael yo you
may have seen me on america's got talent
oh michael you were so good you put the
tea in talent and hello everybody i am
nikki novak i am a television host from
this is my home los angeles california
where there is also a lot of talent now
we're going to be counting it down in
every time zone in my beautiful home las
vegas we're going to be watching all the
great parties you know what's better
than one party michael yo what's that
four parties we are going to be counting
down the new year from four different
time zones we're gonna be kicking it off
from times square and that famous ball
drop we're then gonna be going to dallas
and denver with some amazing fireworks
shows and then finally the fabulous las
vegas where we're gonna watch fireworks
from seven hotel room shops and we
haven't even got to the entertainment
yet it's an intimate concert with
country superstar scotty mccreery you
know who i also love who's gonna be
performing what is cirque du soleil when
they do that thing when they let me show
you
no no no no no we don't know please
don't put your leg up blue man group
will be there as well hi this is zoe
bowie coming to you live from
elvis's iconic dressing room here at the
west gate las vegas we are so excited to
spend new year's eve 2022 with all of
you see you then
well we want you to join in on the party
as well we want you when you use that
social media use the
vegas n-y-e we're going to be checking
out all your party pics whether you're
with your crew or your solo doing the
selfie thing like i do a lot yeah check
it out countdown to 2022 is going to be
airing on 14 different stations all
owned by nexstar they're all down the
west coast across the southwest and you
can also stream it on their websites so
please join us as we ring in the new
year we cannot wait to see you we can't
wait we'll see you we'll see ya we're
ready
i'm ready i'm wearing sequins yeah she
is she's already ready